hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason io
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
this is another one of my core concept
videos which is designed to help
students and lifelong learners
understand
how to apply
how to make sense of utilitarian moral
theory so we're thinking mainly in terms
of bentham's
quantitative utilitarian theory
not necessarily mills qualitative
utilitarian moral theory although that
could be applied to these things as well
and the the types of examples and
applications that i want to talk about
in this one
all center around
issues of health
and you can look at these in terms of
individual
largely individual things you know if
you're looking at it from utilitarian
perspective
of course you're not just interested in
how it affects the one single lone
individual by themselves you want to see
how it affects other people
and
then we got to think about larger
broader societal issues as well
so i'm not talking in this
about a lot of what we call end of life
issues or anything like that but i am
actually looking at a few other other
things
here in this um
so let's start out by thinking about
taking care of oneself
does that matter from a moral
perspective is that is that an issue
well
from a
from a rights-based perspective which is
the way a lot of people tend to look at
these sort of things
you know whether you take care of
yourself what it is you put into your
body what you do with with your body
your time
all that sort of stuff is you know it's
up to you
and
as americans especially we tend to be
you know very standoffish don't tell me
what to do you know this is where you
know this this is where my rights begin
and and my
um sphere of privacy even for certain
issues begins a utilitarian wouldn't
really look at it that way so from a
utilitarian perspective
the way that you would look at it is how
is it going to affect first of all your
own pains and pleasure not just for the
short term but for the long term what
kind of life is it going to lead to a
life of happiness life of uh
misery or somewhere in between are you
are you preventing yourself from
actually enjoying some happiness
but then you know no man is an island as
they say and very few of us are even
peninsula
how does it affect everybody else around
you
that's an important issue as well
and if we're looking at it just on the
individual scale you're probably
thinking about
how does it affect your family that's a
really big one
but you'd also want to think about how
does it affect your co-workers
how does health and the decisions that
you make in terms of it affect
people more broadly in your society you
know for instance if you go on
disability
and you go on disability through
something that was no fault of your own
then you can't really talk about you
know having made a decision about that
it is a drain on on society's resources
um and that's you know that's a big
issue um
from a utilitarian perspective any sort
of drain like that is going to be a
problem
you have to come up with some sort of
you know if you're going to expend
public funds on something
you have to be able to show bentham
would say
he actually does say this in a lot of
places if you're gonna if you're gonna
tax people to take things away from them
essentially by force
by the threat of force which they
interpret as a pain
you would better be producing some some
higher pleasures that outweigh those
pains as a result
so
if you go on disability because of your
your lifestyle because you deliberately
chose to ignore
information about health and to pursue
pleasure in a you know much more
selfish
self-indulgent
privately oriented
don't tell me what to do kind of way
well you know from utilitarian
perspective you would actually be doing
something wrong
so let's think about the the things that
we talk about the most these days when
it comes to this so taking care of
oneself
what does that involve
diet is a big thing you know
here in the united states we have a lot
of uh
choices when it comes to foodstuffs
and
a lot of people don't realize how much
choice we actually have because they
don't look into it or they don't want to
invest the time and work that's that's
needed in order to make some of the
choices become live active choices and i
think i'll talk about some of those
issues in a separate video i'm going to
kind of skim over that
if you're eating junk food every single
day or even if you're eating healthy
food you're eating too much of it well
then you can you know you can become
obese right
um
that's a problem from a from a health
perspective
and we're in this nation now where so
many people have made bad food choices
over and over and over again and you
know you can say well they don't know
any better
or um
it's too easy to to acquire cheap you
know
empty calories or something like that
and there's some truth to that that's
something we can talk about you know a
little bit later on but when it comes
down to the individual if you know that
something is unhealthy for you to
partake in
and yet you're doing it all the time you
become responsible for that and
how so again from a utilitarian
perspective what's the problem with that
if there weren't any bad side effects a
utilitarian would say hey eat as much as
you want eat as much crap as you want
sugar fat you know just stuff yourself
full because we enjoy that sort of thing
right so from the utilitarian
perspective pleasures are good
what's the problem then
well you know there's a tendon pains
that come with it i mean you can eat too
much and we've experienced this
sometimes at you know thanksgiving eat
too much and then you feel kind of kind
of uh lethargic and your stomach hurts
and some people actually like undo their
belts and things like that
um that's you know
that's not happening all that often
but you know if you eat too much over
time
your body doesn't feel good you start
feeling certain pains
it starts to take a toll on your organ
it starts taking a toll on your your
joints um
i know this apart from from my own
perspective so i'm overweight right i i
should be about 50 pounds lighter than
what i currently am
so you know
you might say well who are you to tell
me about this well you know i actually
know from experience there are pains
that that come with you know having too
much
too much on your frame
um
what else
you know a diet could also include um
what you're drinking you know
if you're drinking too much
you know that takes an immense toll on
your body because you know it's a poison
that's why we like it because alcohol
has these neat side effects and then
we've also found ways to make it taste
really great
uh in a whole bunch of different ways
but if you're indulging too much in it
that has important side effects just
from a health perspective alone
that you know would have a bearing not
only on you but on on your family you
know whether you're able to participate
in activities
whether you're able to to
you know provide as you ought to
how long you live you know i think most
of us who like our family members
would like them to live a long time and
if drinking or overeating or things like
that are leading to people actually you
know shortening their life then from
utilitarian perspective
that that's a bad outcome
if it's hurting other people in the
process
that's a bad outcome
you could also think in terms of example
you know if you are
you know in today's environment kids are
getting a lot of bad messages about food
if you want them to have good messages
about food you got to serve them good
food
you have to serve them decent portions
and this goes both ways too by the way
you have to serve them portions that are
the right size for their developing
bodies
healthy food you know it's okay to have
you know ice cream and candy and stuff
like that every once in a while but not
every single day no soda at every single
meal
you know those are sugary drinks that's
that's just you know sort of common
sense and from a utilitarian perspective
it makes good sense and if you want your
kids to actually follow through that
that yourself
you have to eat that way in front of
them
because it doesn't do any good to
present them uh
you know you enjoying yourself well they
have to sort of
live a life of austerity on the other
hand this is a big issue for girls
especially i think
um
some parents go to the other extreme
and they starve their kids
because they get so obsessed with weight
you know this is a big problem i've seen
this for um you know particularly for
women but i could see men doing this as
well
you know i think about wrestlers for
example on their constant struggle to to
remain at a certain certain weight class
but it's a it's a real live problem for
girls you know
parents saying no you can't eat that
much because we don't want you to get
fat
when there's no risk of the the child
actually getting fat because they're
they're exercising they're they're doing
all sorts of stuff and then you know you
know how you can tell a kid like that
you put them down at the table and you
give them as much food as they want and
they act like they're ravenous so you
know that would be a problem
exercise
you know we all know exercise is
important um
again i'm not a great example with this
in part because
i spend so much time doing sedentary
occupations reading writing generating
course content you know shooting videos
like this this is not a very high
high activity sort of you know process
here i'm not moving around an awful lot
exercise is important if we're not
getting enough exercise just from an
individual perspective
again you could say hey it's my right i
can do what i want with my own body from
a utilitarian perspective
you know the response would be well no
not if it's actually affecting other
people
if you're so out of shape
that you know it requires all sorts of
accommodations to be made for you that
cost other people
pleasures
or cause other people inconveniences and
pains
then you're actually doing something bad
from utilitarian perspective by not
engaging in exercise you know i think
for example when i go to uh sam's or
walmart or you know kmart or these other
stores
where they have these uh
these um
motorized carts you know that you can
sit in
and steer it around
and i see some of the people that are in
them you know and somebody's somebody
might be you know have an oxygen mask
and now okay that makes sense they're
not supposed to be just walking around
they're probably you know
not doing too well right but i see
people who look
pretty healthy
getting in these things
with no sign of shame whatsoever i mean
i would be ashamed to actually ride one
of those things so long as i'm actually
able-bodied
i'd have to get pretty sick or pretty
hurt before i would get myself on one of
those
in part because i think i do look at it
in a fairly utilitarian way man if i do
that i'm using up resources that should
be used for something else
what am i doing
that i think i'm so important
that i don't even have to walk around
probably actually would do us a lot of
good to walk around more wouldn't it
medication you know
again a lot of people don't like the
medications that they have to take and
understandable because some of them have
side effects
i'm thinking in particular of um
you know medications that are that are
prescribed for um psychological
disorders um people go off their meds
and
that's a choice that they make
um and once you do that there are
certain things that are that are likely
to happen and those can be measured out
from utilitarian perspective
in terms of the pleasures that they're
causing one or the pains that one is
avoiding but also in terms of the pains
that it is causing other people or the
pleasures that they are being deprived
of as as a result
you know let's take a sort of silly
trivial example
if
taking your meds while you're in the
apartment next to me
keeps you from
waking up at two o'clock in the morning
and thinking that it's a great idea to
turn your stereo on full blast
then um
you probably ought to take your meds
because when you do that now you're you
know engaging in some pleasure for you
you're really irritating me
and probably everybody else around you
in the complex
and if taking your meds would keep you
from doing that
that's a gain from utilitarian
perspective
you know when it comes to other meds
you know if a doctor prescribes you
something and you can get it fairly
cheaply and for a lot of things you can
get it fairly cheaply if you look at it
you know for a broad perspective
if it's going to keep you from having
more problems later on then you probably
should do it preventative medicine you
know what about things like stretching
you know doing yoga massage you know
breathing exercises all those sorts of
things
well again from utilitarian perspective
for the individual person they probably
ought to be doing those sorts of things
uh in part because they're it's going to
make them feel better but in part it's
going to lead to more
pleasures and less pains for the people
around them you know
if i have a bad temper
and doing relaxation
exercises each day helps me not to be a
jerk to my co-workers
then you know bentham would say you
should be doing those those exercises
even if you find them hokey and
irritating yourself for a while
because you're you're you're making a
better environment for people overall
remember utilitarianism maximizing
pleasure minimizing pain for
the general community
so i think that's enough about taking
care of oneself now let's think about
you know ways people don't take care of
themselves like you know engaging in
risky behavior from a health perspective
so you know what would this include well
um
i had a friend
uh who used to do backyard wrestling
and
they would do some crazy stuff i mean
you know the moves that people do in in
you know wrestling which we know are you
know kind of kind of fake
they actually require quite a lot of
athleticism to do anyway though
um these guys sometimes would do these
things for real and they would do other
things like you know hit each other with
with light bulbs you know and get glass
on each other and then they'd have
barbed wire and stuff like that
and sometimes these guys get pretty
messed up
one time the cops actually came hand
and you know
gave them all i think a stern warning i
don't think anyone actually went to jail
for that but why did the cops come
because you're not supposed to be doing
that you know you're not supposed to be
fighting without a license why because
we want to regulate that to make sure
that people are getting more hurt than
than we actually expect well that would
be an example of engaging in risky
behavior and you know if you're a single
guy on your own who's got too much wild
oats that he needs to sew
and you want to get yourself into a
fight club or something like that i
suppose you know from utilitarian
perspective that would be less
taxing you know less of a bad idea
than somebody who's got a family that
maybe he's providing for
or that this is taking time away from or
an injury will will keep him from being
able to
meet the needs of
what else
you know
engaging in in risky sexual behavior
um sleeping with anybody
uh under the sun without any sort of
protection from utilitarian perspective
in today's setting really really bad
idea right because there's a lot of
terrible diseases out there that are not
too difficult to acquire
and
once you've got them now you actually
become a public health problem yourself
from a utilitarian perspective
drugs you know engaging in in
certain kinds of drug use
well most kind of drug use really when
you get down to it
are probably going to be a bad idea from
utilitarian perspective
um so yeah why why is engaging in risky
behavior a bad idea
it's probably going to provide you a lot
of pleasure that's why people engage in
risky behavior there's actually you know
some people get a real charge of doing
something wild
so that actually increases the pleasure
which you know if you're if you're bent
them you say okay now we've got a higher
bar that we need to meet
but how many people does it affect how
many other people
how many other people's lives does it
lower the amount of pleasure that would
be the question he would want to know
most of the types of risky behavior that
we tend to say hey that's a bad idea
tend to be types where
however much pleasure the person is
experiencing it tends to be worse
outcomes for
everybody else across the board
and um
you know we'd have to say the balance of
pleasures and pains goes against that
now here's two other really interesting
things to think about from utilitarian
perspective
going into work sick
or sending your kids to school sick
we all do this i think i know i've done
this plenty um not so much with the kids
but
with myself um
and in part it comes from uh
on my part at least it comes from this
sense of
hey you know
suck it up you're you're not so sick
that you can't go in and you know do a
lecture or grade some papers or
something like that you know i'm i'm in
some sense a workaholic which probably
from a utilitarian perspective you know
is not taking care of myself right it's
not balancing pleasures and pains
rightly
should i go into work if i'm if i'm
actually sick if i'm likely to
make other people sick as a result
probably not i should probably take a
sick day you know a lot of this depends
on the capacity to actually exercise
sick time and stuff like that i remember
when i was back in in the army a long
long time ago
we we had sick call but you had to be
really really really sick before they'd
actually let you go on sick call and
they'd they'd put it to you like this
they'd say well you can go on sick call
but uh it's gonna reflect badly on you
if you're if you're not really really
sick
you know we don't want people doing that
sort of stuff so we wouldn't go on sick
call so we had injuries that we you know
just sort of
took care of ourselves and uh
you know in retrospect it was a really
dumb idea
we have a healthcare system in part to
try to keep people from engaging in this
kind of behavior that that would make
for a worse
situation for uh for other people should
i require students to come to class even
if they're sick
that's you know that's kind of a tough
call too
um if you think about it how much are
they actually learning if most of their
class is occupied with
how bad they feel wiping their nose
trying not to cough and bother the other
students
and thinking about oh i just want to get
back in bed probably not that much and
probably actually by requiring them to
be there i'm probably actually causing
them more pain
so i should probably be more flexible uh
attendance policy that i currently have
sending your kids off when they're sick
a lot of people do this in part because
you know this is where we can actually
measure things in terms of dollars and
cents
um if you're gonna keep your kid
home
you gotta take a sick day usually
or you gotta find somebody else to watch
your kid
um or i suppose you could send them to
to daycare sick but that's really the
same same thing as sending them to
school sick
you know this is where you got to think
about things in terms of how is it
likely to affect other people if you
send a kid who you know is sick
in with a bunch of other kids and you
know the way the kids behave you know
they're not the cleanest animals on
earth
um
they're gonna get other kids sick
and that's that's a negative utility
right it's
it's causing a negative outcome for for
other people
these are you know fairly individual
kind of things let's think more about
big picture
societal kind of things
a lot of debate about providing health
care
whether as a society
we ought to be providing health care
to everybody
what level of health care we ought to be
providing you know what degree of choice
we want involved in that
all of those are things that i think
could be analyzed from a utilitarian
perspective but it would take a lot of
work to actually do that and most of the
people involved in these sorts of
debates tend to quote the studies that
back up their side or their preferred
plan or
something like that
let's say we back off from all the the
political machinations and buzzwords and
things like that and we think just in
terms of
providing basic health care
universally is that a good idea or is
that a bad idea we we put aside the
worries about is that going to destroy
the insurance market who's going to pay
for this and all that let's say we just
analyzed it in terms of you know of a
kind of government run
option and we say okay it's going to be
paid for by taxes and let's say we
actually assume there's a big assumption
i understand that that it would be
fairly efficient right
would it be a good idea overall so when
we're thinking about things in
utilitarian perspective we can think
about current things how they currently
are
and
what it would be like if we if we did
that
would it lead to an increase in utility
a greater overall balance of pleasures
over pains
if we in fact had universal
across-the-board healthcare not cadillac
healthcare you know where everybody gets
you know everything that they need but a
sort of minimum level across the board
and then i suppose if you wanted better
stuff you could you could spend your own
money on that
i would i would guess
that from utilitarian perspective the
answer would be yes that would in fact
be
better because the people who deb who
tend to get pretty sick
or who get caught in the system and
unable to you know say get insurance
providers to actually pay for things
they're pretty unhappy
um and you know people aren't happy when
you raise taxes
but they're not so much unhappy and
everybody can relate to the possibility
that they're gonna get sick or somebody
else that they care about is going to
get sick
that it makes some sense i mean you know
really if we were going to do that sort
of thing it would have to be across the
board so we would do things also like
get rid of congress's uh free health
care stuff all that they'd go into the
normal system like everybody else and
they would have to suck it up like
everybody else so they'd have to have a
real incentive to make sure
that it's a livable system that there
aren't a lot of there's not a lot of
corruption and waste and all that sort
of thing going on as a matter of fact
i think from a utilitarian perspective
you could actually make a really good
argument that
congress people right we can do this for
two things this is a digression but
congress people
get really good healthcare
for life
and most of them don't send their kids
to public schools
when they're residing in in washington
dc
um
so here's what i would actually suggest
from utilitarian perspective small
amount of people are being affected but
they have immense power
they and their families ought to be
required to go to the crappiest
hospitals in their their areas
and participate in the lowest level of
healthcare available
they also ought to their kids ought to
be sent to the lowest performing schools
in whatever district they're living in
and if they're if they're spending a lot
of time in washington they ought to have
to go there
and everyone knows the washington po
washington dc public schools are just a
nightmare
for the most part
so i think that would actually lead to
some some pretty significant legislative
change and and oversight about these
sorts of things and really change the
conversation
not only for the republicans but also
for the democrats who are
total hypocrites when it comes to this
kind of thing
okay back to my my uh thing so providing
health care you know a good thing
overall yes it extends life uh
it allows greater capacities for
pleasures it it hopefully eliminates a
lot of pains it does cost in terms of
pains
for providing those sorts of provisions
and i think you'd probably have to build
in something so that these you know
can't just keep blossoming and
blossoming the way that they are
um that leads to the second thing what
about rationing or triage
you know you have finite
resources available for
dealing with sick people
and you can see this in emergency rooms
that's where you know triage is
particularly important that's why you
might sit for a long time in some
hospitals waiting to get treated because
the guy who's got the gunshot wound to
the head is going to go ahead of you
because you know he's closer to dying
than you are with your
your nail and your foot or you know
whatever else happened you know the cut
your thumb or
got a concussion or something along
those lines
does triage make sense from utilitarian
perspective yeah i think it makes
complete sense from utilitarian
perspective what you're doing is you're
identifying where the greatest payoff in
terms of spending
resources which is a loss
are going to come and then you're
dealing with that and then the other
things you're sort of arranging in in
order of priority
based on
you know what your your ratio of good
outcome is to investment of resources
um
rationing when you have universal
healthcare you do have to have rationing
you can't provide everything to
everybody
i mean you have rationing one way or the
other not everybody's getting everything
it's just a question of how do you
actually apportion
the rationing is it some sort of
rational
fair procedure or is it just sort of
haphazard whatever you know ends up
falling out you know or is it done
according to who knows who you know some
sort of corrupt process
does rationing make sense from
utilitarian perspective i think yeah it
does again for the same reason that
triage does
there's diminishing what we call
diminishing or marginal utility
for investing in certain kinds of things
so you know plastic surgery for example
there are some legitimate needs for
plastic surgery somebody is in a
terrible accident their face is
disfigured
great provide them with plastic surgery
somebody once have a nose job because
they get made fun of for having a big
nose
uh
i don't think that's quite as important
i don't see that as quite uh you know
the the payoff in terms of pleasures and
pains
somebody wants to have plastic surgery
so they can go to hollywood and compete
with the other people at plastic surgery
no that should be a completely elective
procedure that they should have to pay a
lot for
and nobody else should be paying for
that would be you know an example of
rationing
let's move on there's a couple other
really interesting issues here to think
about
disclosure of health risks
we currently have this this set of you
know procedures and laws that we put
under this umbrella hipaa
means that you can't really disclose
much about somebody's medical records
to another person
you can't even ask about a lot of things
is that a good idea or is that a bad
idea
well think about uh some famous cases
where somebody was sick
typhoid mary
i don't know if you know about her
she was a food worker who infected she
was a carrier of of a you know terrible
disease and you think about all sorts of
cases like this where there's people who
are
carriers and
she was she was a you know a cork by by
a profession
she kept on doing it she knew she was
carrying the illness but she felt she
needed to work and they managed to sort
of track her down
and
eventually they sort of took her out of
circulation but a lot of people got sick
in the process
if somebody's carrying a deadly disease
should we reveal that to other people
should
the need to protect other people from
getting sick and thereby experiencing
pain
displeasure
you know discomfort
unhappiness misery even sometimes
horrific deaths
does that outweigh that person's right
to
something like privacy
or you know to to not be
looked at in a certain way let's say you
know there's a social stigma about a lot
of diseases
well you know from a utilitarian
perspective
at least if we're looking at in
quantitative utilitarian terms
i think that there's a good
argument
for publicly disclosing at least certain
kinds of diseases maybe having alerts
you know
maybe for people who are engaging in
risky behavior and have diseases as a
result
you know certain venereal diseases or
you know kinds of hepatitis from drug
use or things like that
maybe it wouldn't be a bad idea
for other people to to know about that
um
again you'd have to weigh you know like
if the stigma is particularly high that
might actually be enough to say well no
the displeasure caused by that
and you know the social disruption
caused by that and the other
displeasures following from that would
outweigh the the the
other you know
displeasures that would be caused by by
putting people at risk
inoculations
a lot of people don't like inoculations
because they're worried that um
you know there's connections autism or
to other other risks and you know really
if the if the um
if they wanted to put that stuff to bed
they probably ought to do more studies
and uh the doctors that are on one side
ought to not be quite so condescending
to the doctors
and the parents and people like that on
the other side i don't have a dog in
that fight myself
i'll tell you my kids got got inoculated
i don't have any problem with that i
don't have any problem with inoculations
because i was in the military and i had
to be inoculated against all sorts of
things
um
but
i can
understand the argument
that um
you know we have to look at what the the
the risks are in inoculations there are
some risks some people do get affected
badly by them
um what are the trade-offs
think about you know something like uh
there was a big problem just several
generations ago polio
if you know anybody who's actually had
polio and i've known some people in my
my parents generation
it's horrible
it it really did a number one that lasts
the entire person's life
it's disfiguring
it was eliminated almost entirely by
using inoculations by wiping the disease
out
from utilitarian perspective
the amount of misery or unhappiness
that's prevented by inoculations
outweighs the even certain
risks that some people are going to get
sick from it
if the number over here is much much
greater of the total
pleasure allowed or you know the misery
that's prevented
in comparison to the small amount that's
coming from the people who do get sick
this outweighs that
antibiotics another big issue these days
way too many people taking way too many
antibiotics
we see what the effects are
antibiotic resistant
bacteria
and
was a bad
you know bad idea it was a lot of
individual decisions that led to a
a overall structural problem that now we
have to we have to find some way to deal
with now we've got some antibiotic
super bugs out there and we're gonna
have to figure out how we're gonna deal
with that and you know the answer isn't
more antibiotics
because they're antibiotic resistant we
have to find some way to deal with that
from a utilitarian perspective you you
could have made an argument back then
that antibiotics ought to be
somewhat limited in their application
and use nothing like the massive you
know use them for everything kind of
regime that we've had over the last 20
years
it's too late now unfortunately so
that's a retrospective
last one i'll talk about quarantines
again that'd be very similar to this
disclosure of health risks or
inoculation
when people get sick
and they've got some sort of you know
highly
contagious
high risk high damage
kind of disease
should they be quarantined now think
about it this way if you quarantine
people
they are probably not going to be
getting good health care they are
probably not going to have a very good
quality of life
imagine quarantines like the old days
where they just put a cording around the
area and anybody who tries to get get
through they shoot
you know that's what used to happen in
the old days or you get stuck on a ship
somewhere
and
you're on your own
see who dies who doesn't
meanwhile everybody on the outside
is kept more or less safe
is that okay to do from a utilitarian
perspective
and the answer is yes
if you're preventing much greater harm
from an outbreak that would take place
in the general population by confining
say to a city you know think about
albert camus the plague they quarantine
an entire city because bubonic plague
breaks out
that's better than the whole world
getting it or even the rest of the
country getting it isn't it
you're preventing a lot of harm
by imposing some harm on some people
the question though is not whether you
don't impose harm on anybody it's
whether you impose harm on this
population here which is much smaller
or whether you allow harm to occur to a
much larger population from a
utilitarian perspective that's a pretty
easy one to address the answer is yes
utilitarians would be for quarantines
so
you see there's a lot of applications
for utilitarianism to these sort of
health issues both individual and
societal
i think it's a particularly useful way
not the only way of course again i am
not myself a utilitarian i'm actually a
virtue ethicist
but i think it's a useful way for
thinking our way through some of these
these health issues
that we are facing these days sometimes
in our daily lives sometimes in crises
or in in terms of politics and society
you